This video is brought to you by curiosity strain.
Hey, what's up wisecrack,
Greg Edwards here look ever since the tonight show aired in 1954,
the American late night talk show has been as ingrained in American culture as
baseball, Apple pie,
and using super soakers to drink tequila or hot summer days.
And no one has done more to demean his hollow format and comedian Eric Andre,
who has used a germ where the leave a trail of horrified celebrities,
befuddled pedestrians, and decimated wooden desk in his destructive wig.
But is there more to the bizarre antics in his pension from being gross as
hell? Is this really just a way to smuggle a deeper message to his viewers?
Let's find out on this wise crack edition on the comedy of Eric Andre,
but before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor curiosity stream.
If you're looking for more content to bins this summer look no further.
Curiosity stream has thousands of streamable, documentaries,
and non fiction TV shows on history, nature, science, food,
technology, travel, and more.
They feature shows from some of your favorite smart channels while also hosting
exclusives and curiosity originals. Right now I'm watching dream the future.
What's the Gorney Weaver,
a series that explores our technology shapes us and how the future may be
impacted by our innovate.
I love that curiosity stream is available on most devices, including Apple,
Android, and your smart TV. So you can watch anywhere. Anytime.
If you click the link in the description or go to curiosity, stream.com/wise,
crack right now, and use cold wise crack.
You can get a whole year for just 1499. You can cancel at any time.
So what's the rest. Check it out by clicking the link below.
And now back to the show, here's a quick rundown for the uninitiated.
Andre is a standard comedian.
Racial sensitivity training. He started saying the N word like crazy.
They're like, dude, this is supposed to have the opposite effect pop up active.
How did you learn to do that?
What the same way everybody learns the day I hit puberty wizard appeared.
And dystopian talk show hosts who since 2012 as hosted the Eric
Andre show on adult swim with the side, the hilarious handlebars,
it features a mix of in-studio bits.
Interviews you ever heard of a robot before.
I don't even know what that means. Hidden camera pranks.
I'm Mr. Burrito, the human pizza. We spoke earlier. I'm from the pizza society.
And I'm here to talk to you about pizza safety and.
The occasional musical guests. [inaudible]
It's often very weird, usually very funny.
And if you watch it up and so with your step-mom Gayle,
she'll be very confused and extremely concerned,
but gal can be assured that Andre's more than just goofing around. In fact,
he's working in the vein of a tradition first use to describe gross looking
Roman ruins and later applied to everything from weird gargoyles to
carnival and freak shows the grotesque while the girl says was once used as a
way to strike the fear of God into the illiterate masses with this nightmare
fuel, it really became what we know it as today at the turn of the 20th century,
when the Italian playwrights created what critics call fear of the grotesque,
the grotesque is more than just being gross.
It's about transgression by pushing boundaries and celebrating the abnormal.
It helps us better understand our allegedly normal world.
Andre is far from the first person to use the weird and uncomfortable for
cinematic effect. Filmmaker,
John Waters put his name on the map for among other things,
making a movie where the main character eats dogs.
Then there's David Lynch who was more partial to separate years,
but in Andrea's case,
the normal world he's transgression is the celebrity world.
And what better microcosm of that,
then the talk show and doing so he wants us to question how normal the
entertainment world is after all.
You only need to look as far as the opening credits to know that the Eric Andre
shell is going to be a million, middle fingers to Jaylin Owens,
Jimmy Fallon and all their guests where a traditional show is a house band
playing crowd, pleasing, jazz.
[Inaudible].
Great house bed OS for the John was discorded a chaotic cousin.
Well,
our traditional opening credit sequence might have some B roll of the house.
Our city skyline,
Andre uses this time to psychotically destroy his set and occasionally get his
sex fault raided by the fence.
[Inaudible].
It seemed bizarre and arbitrary.
It destroys the illusion of normalcy that surrounds the late night format,
giving the audience a taste of what's to come.
The same can be said in laundries interviews with celebrity guests,
during which he'll do anything from Santa rat, moose
Tend to actually pee his pants by making these interviews as weird and
unpredictable as humanly possible.
Andre is transgressing the normal formula for how a host is meant to interview
guests, a formula defined by prescreen,
softball questions clear sat us for plugging their newest product or bill
and so on. Are you proud of it? Are you aware of how good it is and in doing so?
Andrea exposes just how meaningless scripted and sometimes straight up stupid
these interviews and other talk shows trumps really are the shooting of your
onstage band. Really any more fake than rehearse pleasantries. All right.
Maybe it is a little more fake, but still,
and while it might at times seem like he's just being a Dick.
According to Andre,
it's not just about making somebody uncomfortable or harassing somebody or
giving somebody a hard time.
I set out to be the most incompetent talk show host of all time.
It's more about blowing the guest's mind,
having them feel sort of an out of body experience.
He's the Morpheus of pop culture, if you will,
but Andre isn't just transgressing the polite handshaking of meeting Jennifer
Lawrence on the tonight show, but pushing boundaries in his real world stunts,
we can start to ask similar questions about the lines he's crossing.
Then take the time to Eric ran through a civil war in magnet as a shackled
runaway slave.
And because Andre has a tendency to push the line until he can't push any
further, there's a slave catcher chasing up with a whip
while laundry stuff. Certainly weird. It forces us to ask more basic questions.
Like isn't it more weird that people do historical reenactments without
addressing certain conveniently on minute details.
Andre even said in the interview that the idea came to him after seeing the ad
for colonial Williamsburg where, well,
my black brothers and sisters getting their reenactment on.
And then I was like, Oh yeah, black people.
Weren't having a good time in the real colonial Williamsburg is
Andre the weird one?
Or is it the people who dress up as soldiers defending slavery by disorienting
our perception for a second, we're able to see the situation for whatever. Yeah.
[inaudible] I don't know about you,
but I like to dress up as a member of the Chilean death squad on the weekend for
the history. If most artists,
an active expression of norms like Norman Rockwell painting,
celebrating the joy of getting together and murdering a nice juicy Turkey.
The growth task is about questioning those norms at every step.
Andre is trying to achieve something similar.
When he runs into a tea party meeting to kindly let the attendees know,
it might be absurd to jump on a stage and an Alex Jones, a man,
and then self identify as a novelist. I'm not a Democrat either. I'm a nihilist,
but we can also ask isn't Joe's brand of snake oil fueled,
conspiracy politics, deeply nihilistic. In the first place,
we might compare Andres out of studio antics to those of say David
letter, Laderman broke up the monotony of studio time with almost purposely
non-confrontational humor like strapping,
a camera to a rollerskate monkey are literally dropping random things off
buildings. I don't leave the boy that any iota of social commentary,
these stats are put in stark relief by the wild and Cindy era political
ads, Andre incorporates into his show by turning of a law,
reenactment or political rally into a situation that feels that normal and
unstable. We're forced to see the normal in a whole new light.
Here's my hotel Canon well you'd have sex with my wife. If you drop acid,
before you watch the 1998 remake of the parent trap,
he realized that it's actually a film about how all Americans have a split
consciousness on one side,
we're rugged American individualist and on the other British knobs.
And those hands are always trying to re-ignite for that.
Our parents will love and accept us,
But he didn't think we're going to skip the real nasty digits. I mean,
quite little.
This is the back of my face.
[inaudible].
Godrej has a deep love for all substances capable of being expelled from the
human body.
Take the iconic example of Andre's interview with Lauren Conrad star of
MTV's the Hills, her publicist,
clearly hadn't done their homework and it's from the moment she walks on set,
she's visibly uncomfortable, but always wanting to be a good house.
Andre goes the extra lanes to make sure she's relaxed by volunteering on
his desk and then eating it in front of her. In case you listen to it,
he first pukes all over his desk and then he tries to suddenly eat the puke.
Conrad responds by getting the hell out of there.
So is there any way to explain this that doesn't end with,
and that's why Eric Andre is a discussing human who never should have been given
a cell in a set of watching it. We should all just watch reruns of Alan,
a host we can admire for kind treatment and mothers.
Here's what Andre later recounted and an interview about Conrad.
I'm not trying to be a Dick. She's cool. I have no beef with her. It's just,
you know, I'm a psychopath when I'm doing the interviews. Oh,
she doesn't take it personally, but she didn't like it too much.
Here's the deal. We walk around in our day-to-day lives, wearing clothes,
eating well prepared meals and wearing masks over on disease halls.
Trying to get that underneath all of our civilized practices.
We are animals that fart and burp and and protect our
environment. And Brittany Johnson's night break. Wardee even worse,
Andre and volts. This humbling,
embarrassing feeling in front of quote unquote celebrities.
Their entire careers typically depend on our belief that they're are larger than
life, that they almost certainly transcend the disgusting reality of their farts
loudly reverberating in the toilet bowl in the shared office bathroom. Sorry,
Jared, my bag. All right. What's more he does.
So on the squeaky clean suit clad turf of the talk show where hosts focus on
family friendly, zingers and topical, but not edgy commentary.
It's also worth mentioning that late night hosts Jack Paar got in trouble for
making a joke about the water closet in 1960, by contrast,
Andre spent an entire year now grooming himself before the filming of his fourth
season.
Not even letting the costume department ever wash his suit like James
Corden, singing carpool karaoke. Andre is reveling in his own filth,
but all of that said his air gross hell yes. A hundred times.
Yes, he's so gross.
And it's shocking that he's been able to land so many seemingly normal romantic
partners like Rosario, freaking Dawson,
who was now dating Senator Cory Booker. Andre is gross,
but he is using this Grossman's to create his own theater of the grotesque in
which he is pushing boundaries and testing limits to make us think about how
weird and often disgusting our supposedly normal world is.
And just like a batch of your cousin, Scott, special brownies, they're gone.
Dre show was able to blow our minds and make us see things in a whole new light.
So next time someone calls you weird for eating an ice cream sandwich and a
shower,
a gross for throwing up all over wall street or a criminal for having a
contest to see how many babies you can hold.
You can respond by simply explaining that like Eric, Andre,
you are an artist using the grotesque to push the boundaries of experience,
but while you think why is crack,
does he just a nasty comedian or is there a method to his madness?
Big thanks to our patrons for supporting our channel and the podcast hit that
subscribe button. And as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].